let's definitely just at that you don't
drink fast enough to be a housewife you
know this in your last year too hey guys
I'm Bryce and ER this is how sex happy
hour and Tamra judge is here to talk all
things OC hello well I before we dive
into all the drama I want to talk about
Kelly what she's really coming hot I
feel like she's only gonna get another
hot oh you haven't seen anything yet
Kelly is the most confusing cast member
i have ever been around in nine years so
it looks like at the 70's party is when
things are really going to jump off the
cliff that's when yeah that's when the
show starts getting an epic i like to
put you know what can I going bye-bye
you're my party no wonder why you
cheated on your wife does that not give
you chills or what there was a huge blow
up prior to that a huge blow up so that
was really on her way out Heather and I
said I just want to curl up in the fetal
position on the little shag carpet right
there because I've never seen anything
like this in my life well it's also
Vicki and David get into it at that
party it's cuz you know completely bad
guy I would say this is probably worse
than the 80s party I had worse than the
Bunco party yes I gotta take us into
that it only works when it's to your
beer oh you're up Ricky
I've gotten tweet saying it was to me
and I'm like no I'm not the see you next
Tuesday not this time no that was
actually directed at Shannon Wow yeah
she called me a dumb oh wow did she just
go down the line and say because that's
also the event that leads to Heather
crying it was a huge night like a huge
night of a lot of words a lot of cussing
a lot of fighting I'm surprised somebody
was arrested low face oh um outrank me
so I'll cheers alone I guess shocker to
that cheers thank you for this congrats
on season 11 oh thank you so much i
think it's gonna be a really good season